what do the next six months look like
for both ukrainian and russian forces
let's bring in marina miron she's an
honorary research fellow in the defense
studies department's center for military
ethics
at king's college in london marina it's
good to have you with us this evening so
here we are six months into this
war russia's invasion of ukraine this
week russian president putin said we
need to boost the size of the military
what does that tell us about how the war
has gone so far for russia and what does
it tell us about where it's headed
i think it's an interesting question
because
it is a way a direct reply to the aid
coming from the united states the recent
announcement by joe biden's
administration and i think that is
russia's response signaling the fact
that the war is not going to end anytime
soon
as a matter of fact uh perhaps during
winter
both russia and ukraine will have the
chance to regroup and recover to resume
operations in spring
but we're in for a long haul here
and
the latest 3 billion u.s military aid
package that was announced this week i
mean it includes more high-tech weapons
air defense systems radars artillery
systems i mean what does this tell us
about how the us
now views
the ukrainian military
i think for the u.s it's a sign of
commitment to ukraine because in the
past weeks there have been a lot of
publications trying to discredit the
ukrainian armies their for their efforts
um especially in relation to the nuclear
plant as well as human rights abuses so
it's a sign that the u.s is still
committed to supporting ukraine and that
it believes in the fact that the
ukrainian army can withstand russian
aggression
moreover it's important for the biden
administration given the upcoming
elections in november to set a mark and
hopefully to send a message to the
allies who have been
slowing down their support to ukraine
because of their own national interests
to throw their support behind the
ukrainian army and this has been shown
in recent attacks on crimea and
also the antonovsky bridge which have
been successful from a tactical
perspective so the idea is
supporting more weapons however these
weapons are defensive in nature at least
there is hope that uh um ukrainian armed
forces can stop russia from advancing on
the front lines yeah and these weapons
systems like the high mars rocket
systems that we know they give ukraine
an increased military punch a boost if
you will
what about the psychological impact
though of these weapons deliveries
what's been the impact of these
deliveries on both sides
i think it's very important to look at
this war from both perspectives there is
an information dimension to this war so
announcing
these deliveries is
strategically a mistake because the
enemies of russia
is
knowing and is preparing for the fact
that these deliveries will take place
and we'll be trying to get information
on where
um the logistics the logistic routes are
and try to target them so you think that
you think the us so you think the us
should keep this secret when it is
planning to send another billion or two
billion dollars of weapons to ukraine
i believe it would be wiser but as i
said there are two dimensions to this
there is a psychological dimension and
the morale of armed forces of ukraine
is crumbling their war fatigue same as
the russians so it's important to show
that the west is still behind ukraine
and that they are getting the support
that they badly need
and this reinforces the position of
zelansky as a president who can keep his
promise to deliver these weapons to the
front
however there is a downside that the
russians um they should be deterred by
hearing that that ukraine is getting
these weapons however that also gives
them the chance to prepare
they are waiting in anticipation they
know what's coming and what's going to
be facing them
and from that perspective it's not very
wise to disclose what exactly is being
delivered
and in what quantities or what types of
weapons
i want to ask you we heard a lot at the
beginning of this war about the fears of
large-scale cyber attacks
from russia in retaliation for western
weapons supplies or for economic
sanctions but you know the the the fears
have not been
borne out
in reality have we overestimated
russia's
cyber
capabilities here
i think it's quite an interesting
question that gets posed quite a lot
because everybody was expecting a new
cyber holocaust and there have been
indeed some isolated cyber attacks which
on the battlefield preceded kinetic
strikes however we haven't seen the
full capability of russia's
cyber arsenal and the reason for that
can be a that they are lacking
these capabilities however the more
likely scenario is that it's not
worth um stepping up the stakes and
showing their hand because essentially
ukraine is not the main enemy for russia
it's a nato alliance and so
using their secret weapon their war
winning weapon because that cyber has
been described as such by russian
sources early on in the ukrainian war is
just a waste for russia because there is
a fear that
these weapons will get out there and
will be reverse engineered
the same way it happened with sand worm
so there is no strategic utility as of
now i mean in terms of military
equipment russia is not leading a war
russia is leading a special military
operation it's not committing all of its
forces it's not committing all of its
technology to ukraine
so that same logic applies to cyber just
they are keeping the best for
later on when when the real danger of
confrontation with nato states um
looms closer that's
more likely when russia will try to use
its offensive cyber and probably not
against ukrainian targets but rather
against western targets yeah and
we certainly hope of course that day
never comes marina maron from king's
college london marina we appreciate your
time and your insights thank you
thank you residents of a small town in
eastern ukraine are burying their dead
after this week's devastating russian
attack on the ukrainian independence day
at least 25 people including two
children were killed by russian rockets
in the small town of chaplina our
correspondent attended the funeral of
one of the children who was among the
victims
matli would have had his first day of
school next week in peaceful times
the six-year-old boy will not live to
see this day anymore
the whole neighborhood came to say
goodbye
he was the most precious thing in my
life it's also incredibly sad
for my daughter there's nothing left she
doesn't even have a home anymore
matthew was a quiet boy his grandmother
says his home was directly across the
street from the town's train station
the family was just getting ready for
dinner when russian rockets started to
strike the neighborhood
machu was playing in the living room
when the shelling started
and then he ran over to the kitchen
where some other family members were and
that's when the rocket hit and killed
the little boy immediately
russia claimed responsibility for the
attack the military said it wanted to
destroy a train that was supposedly
carrying ukrainian soldiers and they
apparently considered the death of matvi
and many others as acceptable collateral
damage for their operation it's the
worst tragedy that has ever happened in
the small town of chaplina the mayor
tells us but it brought the community
together
the parents of the dead children have
gone through an incredible amount of
stress
we know it's very hard for them to go on
with life but at least we try everything
possible to support them
besides matli an 11 year old boy from
the same neighborhood died in the attack
the war has already cost the lives of
more than one thousand children and the
two boys from chaplin probably won't be
the last